the key ID property is going to
represent the ASCII value of the key
that was pressed by the user for this
next quiz what we'd like you to do is
exercise what we've talked about in
action you need to create an element
array of 256 values named kisi whenever
the user presses or releases a key you
should mark that state in that array to
do this make sure you utilize the code
that we've already written for capturing
and hooking up the listeners for keydown
and keyup
finally inside of the update function
make sure that you're querying the key
state value to determine whether or not
you should or should not drop the beat
in proper fashion